[Music]
are you guys doing wonderful thank you
and yes so listen man I get to talk
about great movies here at the Toronto
Film Festival I won the lottery it's
fantastic
for real listen be their only reason
Collider gets to be at the Toronto Film
Festival because we have great sponsors
I want to give a huge thank you to
Nordstrom Canada for sponsoring because
they're it's great and it allows us to
cover great movies like this dolomite so
jumping right on in you guys premiered
your movie last night I heard the
premier played like gangbusters what
what is it like to have a movie here
what was it like last night with the the
audience reaction and everyone loving
the movie it was incredible man you know
for us as actors - for us to put the
movie down and I mean not put it down
but to work on the movie and work
amongst each other and then watching on
camera and watch the response was
incredible you know very very listen I'm
a huge fan of Eddie Murphy and I love
when Eddie Murphy is acting like doing
the this role he's fantastic in it for
all three of you talk a little bit about
getting to work with Eddie in this
because his work is just fantastic in it
yeah I mean it's a very high pedigree
you're walking into a situation where
you know there's a living legend being
the captain of the ship and you fall in
line and you sit back and you learn and
he was gracious he shared so many
stories about all the movies he's made
over the over the years and it's time on
SNL and it was just uh it was
collaborative as well as you know a
learning opportunity was wonderful
everything is magnified I mean he's
already magnified in my life just being
Eddie Murphy so to be and this proximity
wait a minute and I you know in a limo
when all of us in the limo and heat
cracking jokes and telling stories in
between takes and we're having it is
it's magnify and magnificent it was
I couldn't have dreamt it you know I
would imagine though autumn listen
everyone's a fan of Eddie Murphy so I'm
just curious how much did you pay to
work with him in the movie I donated my
entire check basically like tied to see
it man he's just he's just one of them
guys that you know for what we do he's
like a Mozart you know he's like the top
of the line of what we do acting in film
television you know acting on-screen and
just to watch him work like some days he
would come on the set man you know he
would just appear you know we you know
you usually see somebody show up on set
and I'm just informing they like okay
camera yeah I would have paid I would
have paid to be in a movie but you know
that's another blessing we didn't have
to pay we got paid except his scale but
still the thing is though I'm so
impressed with what Craig was able to
pull off on this because he's making a
period piece he's telling this
incredible story I guess a little talk a
little bit about working with Craig
Brewer on this thing and what he brought
to the table a lot of trust there he he
trusts us to go for it he's set the
story out and you know he come in and
you know when he had to but it was a lot
of like he knew he trusted us with the
material and we carried the ball around
with it yeah he definitely knew what he
wanted to want it and one thing about
Craig he was he's he's very culturally
invested in the work and what he was
working with in these projects
and I think you know the pull of a movie
off like this as a director you have to
be culturally involved invested in he is
that's right he knows what we are and
what we taught me some get the best out
of us you know I mean I hate asking this
generic kind of thing but how familiar
were all three of you with the Dolomites
films and with the whole backstory of
what it took to make that movie very my
mom and her sisters will watch it all
the time and then my cousins would sneak
and get the VHS and we'd watch it and at
the time I didn't know what I was
watching but I said to the fellows
earlier it wasn't until I became an
adult and an actor and a fan of more
sophisticated cinema that I understood
what the nature of his sophistication
was and what he was able to make on a
shoestring budget yeah man I mean
dolomite was I tell people all the time
he was the first Tyler Perry you know
you know how Tyler Perry started off
chillin Cherica chitlin circuit doing
plays and you know that was dolomite
dolomite was first guy who started with
nothing believed in itself made product
for himself and he might have been ahead
of his time you know because we in 2019
everything he's done is making sense now
because the soul is so many people that
follow his path without them knowing and
him knowing either so I wonder who came
up with the turn chitlin circuit and by
the way I love children so I was always
a little fit about a little coleslaw
I've never been a chitlin guy I tried to
eat one one time I got psychological
yeah we know what passes through it but
it's a delicacy well is your from what's
your history with dolomite I had seen
some of the movies and uh but I didn't
learn about dolomite until this movie
and reading a script and then starting
to figure it out who this man was
so I I think this was gonna be great for
people to see that part of them and you
know and the stuff you had to go through
to make a movie I wonder with that kind
of drive and perseverance like what he
would do today like with an iPhone you
know he making a movie day completely
obviously when you step on a set when
you have Ruth's costumes are fantastic
and I'm fantastic
they're amazing so who borrowed type
authority hypothetically who borrowed
what from the costume department and is
that their house right now don't take
from wardrobe so no one has anything she
actually she actually offered to give me
something but it wasn't like a it wasn't
like a movie costume it was some some
jogging pants that we were wearing
in-between outfits
and she's seen the land on a bit she's
on Iran Iran in the trailer she's all
you could have it but it wasn't
something we wear in the trailer was
just like you know it was something
comfy that we wore did I borrow from her
to wear but like he said you don't take
clothes from Ruth Carter man sees them
well I actually wanna I normally don't
ask people about costumes and all that
stuff but what is it these costumes are
so great and they add so much to the
characters that you're playing talk a
little bit about meeting with her for
the first time in finding the character
and the clothes you were gonna wear and
you could talk about that experience
that's often you know one of the final
things I find for me that helps you drop
into the character but I'm sure all of
our feedings were long mine was about
three hours long because I'm a fellow of
a certain size and once we went through
all the clothes and she began to show me
what the
the ensemble's would look like for each
scene and why and whatever it informed
so much of what I was supposed to do and
how I was supposed to do it yeah and I
think those clothes like me and you were
speaking about earlier you know when you
when you shoot a movie it takes every
part of the engine to make the engine
work I'm so every delighting is
important you know definitely the
Wardrobe because you're watching people
you know coming to character clothes
actually help you become who you are is
this invisible theme music in your head
that you hear when you're putting on
these clothes that it make you snap they
make you walk a little different make
you talk different from day one it was
like oh she gets it you know and it does
he felt transported once you you know
put the clothes on look in the mirror I
was doing expands in my trailer laughs
yeah and they felt great you know it was
uh everything it was all custom right
they did and she made sure we were on
point it was it was a wonderful working
her there's no fluke that she got an
Oscar and is on her way to her second
one I she is beyond talented next level
when you you're getting ready to make
the movie it's you're about to start
you're looking at the script you're
looking at the schedule what are you
mole is there like a day or two that you
have circled in advance like I cannot
wait to film the sequence no doubt I
mean when you read a script you read
it's grit well if you could share one of
that day a day or two that you were
super excited to the first day I mean
it's starting especially when you're
getting ready to do a movie with a star
of the caliber of Eddie Murphy you know
the first day was certainly the most
exciting for me for me it was a little
bit the opposite it was like I hope we
don't have to shoot this for a while
and that would be scenes where I had to
sing on camera and I didn't know the
song and Craig Brewer be like hey you
heard the song like no he's like okay
you're doing it tomorrow and so that
kind of stuff happened but I mean I
relished every moment everyone with the
whole set we was fun and love and
respect and silliness all day and I
think Tiny's got tired of me sometimes
but I still I still tease don't project
on the Michele I'm gonna work in a fun
question or two which is ruined the most
takes and why Craig ruined I'll flip the
next question and say who was the
fastest out of their trailer I mean
always I might have been the slowest
faster does not translate to can't wait
to leave work fastest translates for me
is I've been at work all day and I'm
ready to go home
okay one of the things though often
times when you're making a movie and
even on TV you'll the night before
you'll be getting like pink and purple
and yellow pages from script changes how
was it on dolomite in terms of changes
onset if there were changes I don't know
that I've felt them they were larger
overhead changes what everybody you just
do it I mean like you you just do it it
was very loose very collaborative and it
wasn't uh it wasn't too much heavy
lifting when you got these people to
play off of before filming when you're
making a period piece like this when you
have the material of the dolomite movies
and there's a lot of video and a lot of
history to go through how much are you
looking at all that stuff before your
filming and how much are you sort of
just looking at the script and using
that as your base point
if you were making a reinterpretation or
a read Rama decision of something that
already exists not suppose you look to
the source material to copy it verbatim
but this wasn't a rudramma tation of any
of it this was a new script about the
making of something and I know for my
character there wasn't a great deal that
we were able to find and excavate but
what we had we reused so you have to
trust the writing you have to trust what
what they've already given you to be
able to formulate your character and the
world that you were supposed to be
immersed in yeah I agree you know I
think that uh you know a project like
this is you know you get some projects
where where you you understand what the
project is you you know what it is and
then you get some projects where you
have to do a little homework and I think
Rudy ray Moore was really really close
to all of us to some degree you know you
know it's that's our world man you know
and and him being a black man in America
from down south you know we can really
relate to that and him trying to become
the struggle and trying to become
somebody fit in in Hollywood you know I
mean didn't try either he stopped trying
yeah he did he completely start trying
to fit in that's why that's why we had
the movies that we have right because he
completely stopped trying is that [ __ ]
it I'm gonna do it my way and that's
what it's so exciting about watching his
journey it was ya rely on the script one
of the things that I think is great
about the script and is like there's no
love interest for Rudy it's not about
there's like things that maybe could
have been added or whatever but the
script is just it's a great blueprint
but it's it's a really great script talk
a little bit about reading it for the
first time in your reaction to the
material
it was it was like I said it was it was
like reading your own book for me you
know and and and probably for you guys
to 'zed you can speak for it but it's
like reading your own book because he's
like oh wow I've seen I've been through
that before it was all related you know
so when you read something that's
relatable to you it's a feel-good read
it's an excitement you're really ready
to dive into it because it's something
that you understand and you know yeah on
that story his story is ever-present
it is the plight of an artist the artist
its apply to the underdog it's all of
those things no bail yeah hype me up to
to hopefully be a part of it at that
time I was just like you know read the
script me I had to meet with Craig
brewing in I had to audition so but like
like Mike saying is you do see yourself
in the movie as an artist and somebody
who just you know keeps getting shot
down and shot down but believe in
yourself overall so it left me with a
good feeling yeah you never he
sacrificed so much for us unknowingly
you know the things that he was doing he
probably didn't understand the payoff of
what it was gonna be later but he
created a lot of great people out here
you know like I said it unconsciously
people not knowing about it and then
when you get a chance to see this movie
it confirms all of the things that you
went through and we're trying to do and
you know I'm the very nature of how he
made his movies improvisation the
Freestyle the sheer necessity of it all
that is that is the blueprint with which
you know a great many of us are trying
to mount our own little empires today
you know everyone has to find their way
through and that's the beauty of being
human that's the beauty of being an
artist that's the beauty of being a
creator and if you are insecure at
director moving filmmaker after you
watch dolomite you like oh I'm trying it
now nothing I wouldn't mind wait now
it's 2019 look how much access I have
you know yeah completely um listen I
have a million other things but I got a
you have other interviews to do and I'm
just gonna say congrats on the movie it
is so well done and you guys are all
great in it
thank you so much for coming by and
it'll be on Netflix when is it on
Netflix Oh Dena's October 4 it comes on
October 25th theatres October 4th
Netflix October 25th correct absolutely
watch this movie 100% thank you so much
thank you for having us thank you